kicking back and relaxing at the end of  the Working Day for many in Germany  that's no longer the norm they have to  go to their other job in the last 10  years the number of Germans with a  second job has doubled last year over  two and a half million people  supplemented their income with a  so-called mini job that's more than nine  percent of employees with a regular work  contract but there's little agreement as  to what's actually driving Germans to  take on an extra job the government says  people want to earn more to spend more  but critics don't buy them they say  wages in many industries are now so low  that many people can no longer live on  one paycheck alone